Friday marks two years since the fire
that led to the loss of the Las Vegas
icon good evening thanks for joining us
at five I'm Brian Lodge and I'm Denise
Valdez entrepreneur and former Zappos
CEO Tony Shea died in that fire on the
East Coast back in 2020. well today our
8 news now investigators learning more
about his final weeks Alive 8 news now
investigator David charns following
every step of this story David what have
you learned tonight well Denise we were
learning this new information from the
ongoing battle for Tony Shea's wealth
court documents indicating Shea was
getting back on track in the weeks
before his untimely death
Friday marks two years since Las Vegas
entrepreneur Tony Shea died and this
house fire in Connecticut investigators
say Shea was sleeping in this shed with
a propane tank blanket and candles he
died from his injuries a week later
Nucor documents say Shea went to
Connecticut in early November 2020
without his usual security detail his
family writing a new court document that
the trip was an attempt for Tony to get
away from business dealings out west and
away from his misuse of whippets
cartridges full of nitrous oxide the
recently filed documents indicate Tony's
brother was attempting to wean him off
nitrous oxide by controlling his
brother's access particularly during the
trip documents writing over the next
seven days Tony was able to
significantly curb his use of nitrous
oxide he spent his time enjoying food in
movies with his companions his
companions described seeing Tony
beginning to smile and laugh again
now lawyers say Shea's credit ballooned
to more than 250 million dollars they
also alleged he purchased Zappos
headquarters repurchased it just weeks
before his death for tens of millions of
dollars above its appraised value I'm
David charns 8 News Now